are you getting into this election yet
at all this presidential election
anybody know great let's talk about it
that's my favorite thing to do ya know
we don't really care good let's get into
it
no there's it's another day and another
Democrat has announced they're running
for president yeah another one yes
another Democrat just announced he's
running for president congressman Eric
swallow well you know this guy yeah sure
yeah well Warnock this yeah yeah yeah
yeah well this means there are now 18
Democrats running for president and more
are on the way they say yes in fact for
this month only if you announce you're
running for president you can get
all-you-can-eat crab legs at Red Lobster
let's go oh yeah you can see my tax
returns for that sir see true story
congressman SWA well says he's going to
run and his campaign slogan is why the
not that's his 18 candidates you have to
admit one thing about Donald Trump
he literally makes everyone think they
can be President amazing power
[Applause]
my dog is like that's not my dog talks
but alright a little better than Trump
yeah very conservative my dog the
problem is I think if you're getting it
now even now this early you're getting
in late a lot of the candidates have
already locked up their own
constituencies Elizabeth Warren think
about Elizabeth Warren has the female
vote Pete Budaj edge has the gay vote
Cory Booker has the black vote
so soir well is left with the guys named
SWA well vote that's all he has
so now after that little talk I think
you're pretty excited about this
election aren't you
you